the jurogan experience another thing
that's really unusual about you is your
diet yes you're famous you're famous for
eating pasta and homemade pizza and only
eating once a day
every night i eat like this so how this
started was um i've been cutting away
and dieting my whole life right right
and you almost developed an eating
disorder from always dieting and cutting
weight for so many years of your life
right it just naturally happens so
i would binge eat i would starve you
know what i mean like it was very
unhealthy the way i would live how much
weight were you cutting
uh just at a young age cutting weight
you know i would always be cutting like
five pounds 10 pounds nothing crazy but
i've done crazy cuts also so you just
die from those also
but um all that time just messes up your
brain where you never feel like you're
satisfied
and you never full you know so that part
of your brain that says oh you're full
stop eating i stopped having
from cutting weight so much right so
what i started doing was intermittent
fasting
so i would just not eat during the day
because honestly i don't like eating
before training i feel bloated when i
eat so i would just eat at night but i
started just eating the foods i love um
i'm italian so i grew up just eating
pizza and pasta
so i make pizza and pasta every night i
have a pizza oven in my house and i roll
out the dough make everything
and then for dessert i'll eat a pint of
acai
and my weight would be lighter doing
this diet than eating like no carbs and
all these things so my mind i was like
wait i could eat all the foods i love if
i eat once a day at night
you know so it was a no-brainer for me
and my weight is lighter and i feel
better because i'm fasting so i started
doing it
wow so there's no issue with performance
at all that i mean given your blood
sugars and everything like that when
you're training for extraordinary
amounts of time during the day and not
eating
so how i see it is i have to earn the
food at night so training all day is
like me working for the food at night
you know right like how people used to
hunt and gather for food
so that's my mentality
and my best performance in world ge
worlds was in december
i had my best performance ever and it
was on that diet and i made 125 easy
and so when you do like day of
competition same thing you won't eat all
day day of competition i'll change my
diet and i'll eat a piece of bread and
like a little honey just you need some
food in your stomach to deal with the
nerves and adrenaline
that changes for me at least yeah um so
bread and honey huh bread honey rice
cakes just very mild and some sugar
but nothing's too heavy
and when you are getting where's your
protein coming from what i ate a lot of
cheese cheese is that basically all your
protein basically um i eat a lot of
mozzarella um
a lot of parmesan a lot of pecorino
romano
do you put any animal products in your
pizza chicken or meat or anything like
that no meat no meat at all no i love
seafood and meat but um when i'm
training for competition i feel cleaner
when i'm not eating meat interesting
and your body doesn't feel like do you
feel like the protein that you're
getting from cheese is enough
i feel the best when i'm doing this like
i feel like most energy like cleaner i
don't understand how but it works
that's such a crazy diet for you to just
eat pasta and pizza and only eat at
night and then train all day
mo i would most people if you tell that
to they'd go what are you talking about
like if you brought that to a
performance coach oh they would be so
ridiculous what are you doing
have you talked to anybody about that or
they try to talk you out of it yeah a
lot of people said oh that's so
catabolic right because you're breaking
down your body doing it but for me it's
sustainability and i could sustain
eating and training and keeping a
routine doing this and i love my food so
um i don't think i would be able to
compete how i do if i ate normal have
you tried different ways of eating like
different different diets and different
kinds of combinations of food before
yeah i've done every diet before
honestly no carbs high protein a lot of
meat you know but none of them are
sustainable for me this i don't have to
change how i eat when i train right i
could just eat like this and i love what
i'm eating i go to bed with a full
stomach
you know that's i'm happy
i'm always smiling when i'm eating like
this
most people look at you like i've seen
pictures of you without your shirt on
you're so ripped most people don't
believe that that's possible if you're
just eating peach pizza and pasta yeah
well i train all day every second you
know so if you're fasting for 20 24
hours and you just train every second
like your body just burns all the fat on
it right so you're basically eating for
like one hour
i guess yeah and i watch a movie and i
cook and just eat
wow
and that's just your daily routine every
day you know and i enjoy cooking pizza
so after training i'll get like i'll
start making the dough and
so that's my routine every day
and how many pizzas do you eat tonight
one big pizza like
like that fits on the in the pizza oven
you know and about half a pound to a
pound of pasta
and a pint of acai
i i once calculated it it was like 7 000
calories
7 000 calories and do you know how many
grams of protein are involved in that i
eat so much cheese that it was actually
a really high amount of protein
interesting
i've never heard of anybody getting
cheese as their primary protein source
yeah but you need to be an elite athlete
sustainability yeah it's keeping me able
to train and enjoy my training and
keeping me sane well i'm already insane
but it's keeping me more sane how did
did you read about this and decided to
give it a chance or was it something
that you you'd seen other friends do so
i just
i hated eating what happened was i
started doing this because i was doing a
lot of seminars and i would be traveling
all day and i would never be able to eat
when i was traveling then i'd eat a big
meal at night
and then when i started feeling was a
lot of clarity when i started fasting
so i stopped eating breakfast and i
started feeling better training not
eating before training
i'll just drink caffeine so i drink
caffeine during the day
and i feel like that gives me the energy
and i eat so much at night that in the
morning i'm still full from the night
before and i'm just working off the food
and then by the time i'm hungry again
it's nighttime and i'm ready to eat wow
and so who taught you how to make pizza
um my grandma taught me how to make
pizza uh she passed away um like four
months ago but um she taught me how to
make pizza
and when you do it are you making the
dough do you have like a starter like
how does that work so i could make the
dough but with um all the things but it
takes too long i don't have patience so
i just get pizza dough from like whole
foods or like trader joe's and i'll
start with that though but then i'm
really particular with the cheeses and
like i go to like three different
supermarkets for like cheese basil
all the different ingredients so it
comes out really good damn making me
hungry yeah me too i love pizza and
there's something about like a good
pizza that you make yourself in one of
those ovens that you have it's so
satisfying yeah
well it's so satisfying to even to watch
you know yeah and you slice it up and
the melted cheese and you pick up the
first slice oh my
god much more time before you get to eat
um probably tonight again
like it's where it's like 3 22 right now
like depends on the day probably after
this i'll eat like seven o'clock six
o'clock so have you trained at all today
not at all um no because my appendix so
oh
so i'm just doing a lot of cardio right
now and i'm training a little bit but
just very safe when can you go back to
full rolling well the doctor told me
like hard full rolling like middle of
august beginning of august so
i could start then but uh right now just
lighter training just keeping your body
drilling still studying but i just
maintaining right
and so this um one of the things i saw a
video of your whole pizza setup like it
seems like there's a company that you
use and they they send you certain pizza
dough yes what companies are um it's
called kavita for olive oil they send it
from italy um it's an olive oil from
italy and
i also have a pasta that i use and they
send it from italy too so it's just way
better quality what's the difference
i feel like
the pasta from italy seems like it's
less gluten it seems cleaner like when
you eat it you don't feel as bloated um
i it's just different you know um the
olive oil um apparently they don't
change the ph levels in it so in america
all the olive oils have to be like a
certain ph like this is just so natural
they have to be in america i think yeah
because what i've noticed about american
food it's more processed and
every time i travel out of america i get
lighter naturally just not eating the
processed american food it is wild when
you go to italy
um because my family and i used to go to
italy basically every year before covid
and uh everyone's thin
yeah like italians in america are so fat
and that's how i eat my pizza in pasta
it's almost like someone from italy you
know not like american italian food
right so i think that's why i'm so
skinny eating like that does this
company sell pizza dough as well no they
don't i'm getting my pizza dough usually
from like whole foods
so what are they using for the dough
though do you know just regular pizza
dough like i don't care like
i think i whole foods makes it healthier
right because it's whole foods is that
real no i don't think so no but um
just to say that but um yeah it's just
regular pizza dough i use
and so um
you
have basically been doing it this way
for how long
i've been doing it this way since 29
20 20 the last three years wow
three years of just pizza and pasta and
just strangling everybody i feel like
i'm better eating like this i'm happier
happier makes you better in life right
maybe i wonder you know i mean i used to
be miserable dieting all the time yeah
the dieting i think is terrible and i
think that there's some real benefit to
intermittent fasting and there's
definitely some real benefit to giving
your body some time to digest whatever
food that you have i think there's a lot
of people that are like packing food on
top of food yeah you know there's like
this constant cycle through their system
where their digestive system is always
processing things yeah what's important
is what works right yeah no one knows
their body better than a professional
athlete so i'm sure your understanding
of what works and doesn't work for for
your body is pretty finely tuned yeah
you're so in tune with our bodies i
think it's also like a great example of
how much people vary in their
nutritional needs
you know like there's some people that
don't feel good unless they're eating a
lot of meat and then there's some people
who don't feel good unless they're not
eating meat and they're just eating like
the way it sounds like your body is like
very carb-centric yeah so what's
interesting about myself when i was a
kid my parents couldn't get me to eat
anything except pasta pasta with butter
olive oil there's a lot of kids like
that some kids they were like they were
like trying to give me a toy they're
like if you eat this steak will give you
this toy
but my whole life all i ate was like
pasta and pizza so
what's interesting is me eating the food
that i ate since i was a little kid my
body absorbs it the best and i feel the
best eating it so is it because i ate
that for so many years as a kid that my
body just knows how to deal with it kind
of makes sense
yeah it's interesting it's like how
alcoholics can process
alcohol better yeah they're homeostasis
yes so when you go to a restaurant do
you or just order pasta always pasta
pizza that's it
that's a crazy diet man i don't think
there's anybody that i've ever heard of
that's like a legitimate professional
athlete at the highest level that eats
like that do you know of anybody else i
really don't
i don't but it works for me it does work
for you but it's kind of crazy that you
have the courage to try this out and to
do it because a lot of like elite
athletes they will essentially mimic
the
patterns that other elite athletes in
terms of like diet
recovery you know oh that guy won a gold
medal in wrestling and this is what he
does so i'll do that
yeah totally um and i've tried all the
diets like i've been on every diet but
it's not sustainable for me
like um where i could keep training like
i am you know like i feel like i would
want to quit jiu jitsu if i had to eat
like like those diets because i've did
it too many years what have you done
you've done like keto keto i've done
i've done like like five meals a day
like protein small amount of carbs or
where you're deficient in just fat
you're deficient in carbs you're
deficient in protein you know i've done
all of them have you done them under a
nutritionist supervision yes yeah and
this was like while you're trying to cut
weight yeah and i feel like a big thing
is because of the eating stuff i've had
since i was a kid i have a hard time
with portions because of that so because
i don't have to have portions with this
diet i'm able to do it yeah i saw a
video of you at a restaurant with a
giant bowl of pasta and a jug of olive
oil you're just pouring the olive oil
all over the pasta
but i guess you need that those fats
from that olive oil too right yeah and
um it's funny because i once got kicked
out of a pasta restaurant and all you
could eat pasta restaurant for eating
too many pasta bowls come on so i go in
kicked you out they told me i'm done
they like so i go in uh this place was
in uh san jose i go in it says unlimited
possible so the first thing i say to the
person at the front desk what's the
record they're like what do you mean
like how many pasta bowls has someone
ever had and they're like five so now
i'm on both six
and the manager comes over to me like
angry and he's like you're done no more
i'm like but it's unlimited possible he
said your max has been you're expired
wow
what a stupid thing to do but then that
restaurant like a month later went out
of business
so i might have ate them out of business
i'm sure you didn't
but their attitude probably ate them out
of business yeah that's a shitty
attitude like if you say unlimited that
means unlimited exactly and you don't
make someone feel bad for adhering to
the boundaries that you set up
especially i'm not this big fat guy i'm
this small skinny guy i know that's
probably what's really crazy right
you're walking in there 135 pounds
eating six giant bowls of pasta
what a dumbass restaurant